[Music]
well hello everybody
uh i'm trying something a little
different today
i'm speaking with a book club set up by
john velas essentially
centering on bitcoin which is a
phenomenon
that i'm very interested in but know
very little about
i ran across john's podcast
partly because their book club also
focused on my first book maps of meaning
and so
i looked up gigi durr who's speaking
with me today
john vellus richard james and robert
breedlove who make up the four people in
in this particular uh incarnation of of
john's book club i was interested in
their thinking about bitcoin and i
noticed they were also interested in
maps of meaning and so i thought we
could try a
free flowing discussion i haven't done a
podcast youtube video with five people
before so
we're going to see how it goes and
hopefully we'll have an interesting
discussion about
money about bitcoin about maps of
meaning about maps of value
about languages of value about
information
all of that so i'd like to introduce
gigi durr john vallis richard james and
robert reedlove and maybe
i could start with gigi and you could
just introduce yourself and
and we'll move from gigi to john to
richard to robert so gigi it's all yours
yes i'll do my best first of all thanks
for having us it's a great pleasure i
think we're all
great fans of yours i think that's
obvious and yeah about me
i think most people know me in the
bitcoin world because i wrote a little
book called 21 lessons
um it's basically a short summary of
what i've learned from
falling down the bitcoin rabbit hall and
other than that i've been involved in
the bitcoin space for a couple of years
and i've just i've learned a lot i've
read a lot about
it and so i tried to pay the forward and
share it with the community and i think
that's what brought me here
thanks john yeah my name
is john vallas and as you said jordan i
host the bitcoin rapid fire podcast
and uh first i'll i'll echo what gigi
said it's a pleasure to be here
um you know big fan of your work uh have
listened to many hours of your stuff and
of course read your books
um i've been focusing in the podcast
over the last year
on exploring bitcoin and what it is and
what it means and speaking with all the
different people that are involved in it
um but as we told you a bit earlier uh
i've been placing the
the phenomenon that's been most
interesting to me has been the
transformations that seem to be
occurring
in individuals as a result of
understanding and engaging with bitcoin
and it's a very peculiar phenomenon of
course and so that's why i found it so
interesting and of course i think
there's
um the book maps of meaning and part of
the reason why we explored it
in the book club is because i think that
provides a framework for understanding
that phenomenon
better so hopefully we'll we'll get into
some of that today yeah well part of the
reason i wanted to talk to you guys was
because when i started looking into what
you were doing i was struck by
two things that there seemed to be a
psychological element to
your endeavor but also perhaps to
bitcoin and the bitcoin community such
as it is
and then also i was interested in your
philosophical speculations about
the domain of value and so we'll go
delve into that
what have you noticed about individual
transformation and and
do you think it's particular to bitcoin
and like it's a strange thing to to
notice and to and to bring up so
maybe you could elaborate on that a
little bit sure well one of the
the answer is yes and one of the you
know the interesting overlaps between
your work and you
and the changes that uh are represented
in
people that get involved in bitcoin is i
think there's a lot
it there's a lot of the instantiation of
a lot of the things you talk about
are represented in the changes we're
seeing uh in people that engage with
bitcoin and of course notwithstanding
that your
work generally as a permeate permeates
out into the culture
is providing people with ideas to chew
on and that causes some degree of change
but
what i've noticed in people in bitcoin
is that it rapidly accelerates this
change toward
uh taking more responsibility as it were
changing that is well there's a couple
reasons and i think the other aspect
you know to to sum up and not take up
too much time initially here is
is that is it changes people's time
preference as well it changes the
relationship to
time uh and so the first why i think
uh that is is um it's a very
it's a very peculiar thing but i think
the the genesis of it is that bitcoin
allows you
to own something and to have to allow
you to exclusively own something
for the first time ever and that is the
private keys to your bitcoin so it's an
extreme form of ownership
that is not represented in any other
domain of life it's a
inherent property right what do you
think what difference do you think this
idea of
unique ownership makes and and then how
do you relate that or
if you do to a difference in time
preference and what does that mean
well for one i i would say that because
it's the first time
to experience something like that it
changes your relationship
to responsibility and i think one of the
outcomes from that is it it
causes you to contrast that extreme form
of both ownership and responsibility in
that domain
to all the other domains of your life
where let's say there's a dependence
that exists
and so this is kind of the idea of
freedom that bitcoin seems to engender
is that when you take
you know complete sovereignty and
control over the thing that
most reflects you know who you are out
into the social world at the very least
and that is money that is the emblem of
your time and sacrifice
or what you gain rather for your time
and sacrifice once you take control over
that
i think it it provides a you know a very
powerful impetus
to look at other areas of your life and
see where you might establish greater
sovereignty
and take the responsibility to do that
another part of it is is once you come
into this space you start to realize
uh basically the impact of the current
system of money
that we use um and i know this is a term
that you use and you reference in the
book but
you begin to see how bitcoin represents
the information let's say the truthful
speech
that rectifies pathological hierarchies
that evolved as a result of false money
you know as a result of fiat money let's
say and i think you could broadly say
that
money is information regarding your own
value hierarch
hierarchies that you when you
and everybody else right right and so
when you use it you communicate those
and to the extent that there's an
intermediary or that there's
anything that's distorting the fidelity
of that communication
pathological hierarchies incongruencies
between what you're attempting to
communicate
and what you actually are communicating
to that market i think
emerge and i think that was what i found
interesting about the claims that you
guys are making and
i i i wanted to have this discussion in
part two to evaluate that claim
to to see if there's well to see how
solidly developed that idea is because
it's a very interesting idea
that in some manner bitcoin is incur
an incorruptible provides an
incorruptible language of value
preferable to gold say so maybe you have
to buy the argument first that gold is
preferable to a currency that isn't
dependent upon something like gold
and that's also a separate argument but
you're making the case then that bitcoin
is superior even to gold
and so we'll go into that what's your
background john
i started my career in finance i lived
in in shanghai
china for about a decade and then whilst
i was there
i got out of that because i i didn't
enjoy
the incentives that you know the
behavior that came from the incentives
in that industry and i went into natural
medicine
and uh did a degree in that and and
worked in that capacity for a couple
years
and then all the while i had been
interested in bitcoin and studying
bitcoin
and in 2019 it just kind of became
overwhelming so
at the time i was living in thailand and
i decided to start the podcast and
as everyone on this part this this
current uh podcast will attest once you
go down the bitcoin rabbit hole it's
very very difficult to claw your way out
you know you you're attempting to find
the bottom rather than back to the
surface so
that kind of characterizes my pursuit
since uh 2019.
what's your background so i have a
heavy tech background i studied computer
science and i studied a little bit of
physics
and i've been a computer programmer for
the last like
15 plus years um so yeah i think that
sums it up i grew up with computers and
i grew up online
and so i know a thing or two about
distributed systems and those kind of
ideas that are very helpful to make
sense of bitcoin um but still it took me
a very very long time
to make sense of bitcoin like many years
and multiple touch points
because i liked the economic knowledge
that is required to
understand this beast and so the last
couple of years i
um read up on my economics and
discovered austrian economics and that
was
most helpful to make sense of bitcoin
and what right so that's another touch
point because i've become interested
in austrian economics i'm going to be
discussing
austrian economics with some austrian
economists
uh well they're not actually austrian
but they're from that school you also
have a
profound sense of sartorial splendor
just so that you know it
so richard over to you
oh thanks very much dr peterson so
yeah my name is richard james i i'm a
filmmaker by
by trade although um you know in
more recent years sort of worked in
other areas and and just been running a
small business
in a completely unrelated area but i
mean i've had a uh
almost a lifelong interest in economics
and i studied that through school and
into university but sort of
fell out of love with it i suppose you
know i kind of dropped out of economics
at
university but yeah maintained an
interest in that and then
i also came across um the
austrian school of economics and i found
that to be particularly eye-opening
um and it led me down this path of of
asking that question of what is money
and as we've already
mentioned gold plays such an important
role in that and i think that gold
understanding gold is the first step to
understanding bitcoin and so
you know what i in um in the last couple
of years i've sort of
turned back to filmmaking and and trying
to link
that interest to austrian economics and
bitcoin
um and last year i i sort of set myself
uh
a goal for a project to make a film
related to bitcoin and it had two
particular parameters one was that i
wasn't allowed to
spend a dollar and it had to cost zero
dollars and the other thing was i wasn't
allowed to leave my desk
um so i sort of basically put this thing
together
using content that had already been
created by people
um you know working in bitcoin and
talking about bitcoin
and the film's called hard money it's
it's available
free online so that's sort of been been
my contribution i suppose
but i'm yeah more interested in
the philosophy of money the history of
money um
and particularly the phenomenon of
inflation um
and the way that links to things like
time preferences as we've already talked
about
and also i suppose political philosophy
or or
and libertarianism and um
these ideas that there's a certain and
way of thinking um
in austrian economics called praxeology
which is
is about human action and uh and the way
that um you know really analyzing the
way that people
sort of pursue it's very general
general in the way that they use means
to pursue ends like that's the very
first
kind of axiom of the system and from
that we can draw a whole lot of uh
of deductions and um it's interesting
the way that leads you down an ethical
being able to create an ethical
framework as well and that's where
i guess your own work came into it where
you know i found that found myself
interested in this this libertarian
system of ethics or morals
and you know maps of meaning i think is
essentially a book about morality as
well
in that it's a book about how to act so
i found some very interesting
parallels there and what was it about
how would you define the austrian school
of economics and why did it
why was it of particular interest to you
well the austrian school is
i would say it's it's a a way of
thinking
that is about um
logical deduction rather than empiricism
i think the problem with economics in
its current form
uh you know modern economics keynesian
economics because it's largely
influenced by the work of
john maynard keynes i think it uh
it has a problem where it has this
desire to
imitate a physical science you know it
wants to
analyze data um you know get
get complex in a mathematical sense but
there's a fundamental problem there in
that
when you're trying to analyze something
in economics
you know we can't set up an experiment
and
you know run run a test on a parallel
universe we're dealing with
with real world um you know
you can't isolate the independent
variables basically
so it makes that kind of analysis
fraught with a lot of danger where where
is that the behavioral economists are
trying to deal with that to some degree
right by
by running actual economic experiments
they're more like psychologists
they are psychologists fundamentally and
the um the austrian school takes a very
different approach which is to say
you know we'll take a certain set of of
fundamental axioms you know
and then we'll just we'll build our
philosophy based on on logical
deductions so
it's sort of all all done from from the
armchair basically
uh rather than trying to validate
anything via via real world data
i guess the relationship between action
and and economics and value
i suppose is that people choose to act
in relationship to those things that
they value and that
the manner in which they act is all
actually an indication of
what they value and so
money becomes an index of people's value
preferences and
value preferences associated with their
preferences for action i mean that
shapes even such things as perception
right because perception
when we think about that as something
that's automatic essentially because the
world just appears to us in some sense
but
you move your eyes constantly in orient
your head so that you can hear one thing
rather than another and you pay
prefer preferential attention to one
thing rather
than another and you do all of that as a
consequence of
comparative value and i was reading a
book on
on austrian economics last night and
they were talking about trying to define
economics and it struck me that the most
suitable definition was something like
the science of comparative value
it looks like that's what economists
concentrate on
and then money becomes an index of
comparative value and then that leads
that leads well i'm going to talk to
robert next i'll get him to introduce
himself but i know
robert has written a fair bit
philosophically on the implications of
money in general as a signal of value
and of bitcoin in particular so robert
hey jordan uh yeah my name is robert
breedlove it's a great honor
to speak with you today i'll just say
that
your work has had a profound impact on
my life that i'd probably struggle to
put into words so i'll just leave it at
thank you
um i'm a lifelong student of philosophy
and economics
um although more recently thanks to
bitcoin actually was introduced to
austrian economics i've been going down
that rabbit hole for the past four years
my background before that is i have a
master's degree in accounting and
finance
i was a cpa for a number of years so i
did tax strategies for
high net worth individuals investment
partnerships
from there i moved on to be pretty much
a career cfo focused in technology
and then most recently i was operating a
hedge fund before
last year you know 2020 was
transformative for a lot of us
and this quote from h.g wells
really struck me and resonated he said
that
civilization is a race between education
and catastrophe
and my realization is that the world is
so
poorly informed about the socio-economic
significance
and even philosophic significance of
bitcoin that it was
incumbent upon me to take what i think i
see as the solution to many problems in
the world and just pour all my energy
into education
and to that end i started the what is
money show
um i called it this because i do believe
that question
what is money this is the gateway to
this rabbit hole that we've all fallen
down
it is the key to unlocking a lot of the
untruths in the world and i think it's
also the key
to perceiving the corruption that's
embedded in our current socio-economic
system
at the core of which is central banking
which i'm sure we'll get into a lot
today
um and yeah i would just to echo a
couple of the things that were mentioned
earlier
that question what is money has a lot of
answers one of which
is i think you've related in the past is
that money is essentially a contract of
the future
and today fiat currency it's a
violated social contract so we have a
money by which an institution
effectively robs our future they're
compelling the demand for this money
and they're violating its supply to
enrich themselves and dispossessing
everyone else mostly people economically
vulnerable
and to the point about morality it's
like if we don't have a secure social
contract
in the most important market in the
world which is money
then we can't possibly have a foundation
for a sound social morality
so it it it causes people to be more
short-term thinking
when your money doesn't hold value over
time you can't plan
uh you can't create trusting long-term
relationships
and then the the last piece of that is
you know
with central banking violating the
supply of money they are twisting our
perceptions
we perceive the world economically
through prices and when
that perceptive that perceptual
mechanism is twisted it breaks down your
valuations your goal orientations
uh your trust really just trust yeah it
really
corrodes socioeconomic fabric social
morality
uh and even individually to john's point
i think it really breaks us down
and i've experienced that personally in
my life i've i've kind of flown high and
mighty on the fiat currency standard and
i've
experienced a certain set of character
traits developing myself and i've
experienced
an antithetical set of traits uh
developing myself as a result of
studying and interacting deeply with
bitcoin so
can you can you elaborate on that a
little bit you're making a moral
contrast it's personal there's a story
there i'm kind of curious about it so
yeah i um i made a lot of money
quickly at a young age and i would say
that i s
i walked a bit of a darker path where i
just thought that
i had made it i had arrived i would just
kind of party and cut up and travel
i didn't have a lot of i lost that
deeper sense of meaning or sense of
purpose
that that you speak so eloquently to and
you know you don't know it when you're
up against it i still thought that i was
um doing good things and was more or
less a good person but i was just going
further and further off course you know
becoming more and more short-term
oriented more and more
uh pursuing immediate biological
gratification whether it's you know
drinking or or whatever
um and bitcoin and this rabbit hole
just gave me the the larger lens which
we talked about
time preference and when we say lowering
your time preference what we mean is
we're expanding
your time horizons so you're
you gain a greater sphere of concern
let's say beyond yourself
and that that spheric is made up of
space and time and as you do that
you start to see yourself as
increasingly a
more humble and infinitesimal piece of
the total picture
but somehow it also enriches you to want
to really
dig into whatever gifts you have and
give back to the the whole picture
and why do you think why do you think
the fiat currency why do you think the
fiat currency versus bitcoin issue is
relevant to that
conundrum do you know what we could say
in the very severe original state of
nature we're all just
cavemen running around trying to eat um
and
and you know have shelter that is an uh
an environment with a lot of scarcity
right there's a lot of economic scarcity
because we haven't begun to trade we
haven't created the division of labor
and specialization
that creates wealth and i would argue
that fiat currency
because it generates arbitrary inflation
so it's it's artificially magnifying
prices in the world it's increasing
prices when prices should be declining
as we get smarter it's actually
magnifying the perception of scarcity in
the world
and i think that contributes to social
divisiveness up to and including things
like cancel culture and other things we
see in the world today
uh i i really believe that artificial
central bank induced inflation
is a corrosive moral cancer on society
and i think we understand so let's get
some terms straight so that everybody
knows what we're talking about so maybe
we start with
fiat currency and gigi i'm going to pick
on you next because i want you to
give us a technical description of
bitcoin if you would and then we can
start
exploring its psychological and and
philosophical implications
so let's talk about fiat currency
contrast that with a gold standard of
bitcoin and then
let's talk also about central banking
and inflation and just flesh that out so
everybody knows where we're at
that's for you robert sorry that's for
robert i'll get gg i'll turn to you for
the technical description of bitcoin
you'd like me to start with central
banking sure
yeah so to give the very high level
description
again the answer to what is money has
many questions or many answers
but one of them is we could say that
it's a device for moving value or
expressing value across space and time
and historically it's a technology right
the free market
selects what the best tool for the job
is that's true for essentially every
market in the world today
but we've never allowed that to be the
case in the realm of money
um and the best approximation of that
historically was gold
so if we understand that
as a technology money needs to fulfill
five critical properties
needs to be divisible durable
recognizable
portable and scarce and
i'll gloss over a lot of history but
essentially monetary metals
best satisfied the divisibility
durability
recognizability and portability
properties of money
and of the monetary metals gold was the
most scarce
and scarcity of money so what scarcity
means is when demand
outstrips supply but what's unique about
money is that
demand always exceeds supply there's
never
enough people always want more money
right it's not like
you're going to reach a certain amount
of apples in your in your kitchen and
you're satisfied with apples you always
there's always more demand for money
so we could say that money always has
this scarcity property inherent to it
um but the the market gravitates towards
the good
that best satisfies those first four
properties and then fifthly
has the most inflexible supply so
another way to say this is the most
inflation resistant monetary technology
tends to be favored by market actors
because as it turns out surprisingly
enough or not surprisingly
people don't like to get stolen from via
inflation
you want to hold the money that holds
its rarity and scarcity across time
such that no one can dilute you and so
why do you regard
inflation as theft so
inflation it's just very simple supply
and demand economics
if price or purchasing power in the case
of money is where supply
meets demand if someone can arbitrarily
increase the supply
they can steal purchasing power from the
others using that as a store value
so that's why again gold was selected on
the market because there was
sacrifice necessary to obtain gold you
had to expend time and energy to dig it
out of the ground
such that in this game theoretic
selection of money
everyone could trust that no one could
arbitrarily violate the supply of gold
because if they could they would just
print gold if you could and still
dilute it with silver or something like
that that's right on occasion
which they did yeah they've
counterfeited gold and any number of
things
um the problem with gold though
essentially is that
it was great for holding value again
back to our original definition money's
a device for moving value across time
and space so gold is excellent at
holding value across time
but it's a metals are pretty poor
especially for a globalizing society at
expressing value across space
they're very heavy and difficult to move
they're expensive to move expensive to
secure etc etc
so this is where paper currency
was introduced by abstracting gold into
a paper currency
we could now increase its
transactability across space
and so long as it was redeemable one for
one right one unit of currency for one
ounce of gold for instance
then it maintained its uh ability to to
express value across
time as well so we're basically
augmenting this free market selected
technology
to make it more transactable across
space and time
the problem with that of course is that
it introduced
the need first of all it made money debt
so now all of a sudden we don't have
money we have a
paper certificate that's redeemable for
money which is gold
so this this paper certificate becomes a
debt instrument
and the problem is you now needed to
trust the custodian
the bank whoever's holding that gold you
have to trust they will not produce
paper currency in excess of their gold
reserves otherwise
they are then uh the one artificially
inflating the currency and able to steal
from everyone else
and as it turns out you know again money
is like being the most important
technology in the world the temptation
to manipulate its supply
has proven historically to be
essentially irresistible
and banks which tend to become
central banks or nationalized banking
operations over time
have have always violated that trust
function placed can you give us some
recent examples of that
well sure in 1971 uh the infamous nixon
shock he took the world off a gold
standard
you know aft subsequent to world war ii
we held the bretton woods conference
where
it was determined unilaterally by the
united states
that the dollar would be pegged to gold
every other currency in the world would
be pegged to the dollar
so this gave the united states the
infamous exorbitant privilege to just
basically be able to print whatever
amount of money they want
send the world uh these paper
certificates called dollars and then
receive goods and services in exchange
but other countries agreed to this one
because the us was the dominant military
power of the time and two because
dollars were redeemable for gold
but from between 1944 and 1971
it reached a point where enough
countries had had lost faith in the
dollar that they were asking to redeem
their currencies for gold
then nixon decided to spontaneously
close the gold window so he just moved
the world off of a gold standard
onto a purely fiat currency standard and
then there's
since that point actually since 1971
through today it's been about a 50-year
experiment we have had disastrous
socio-economic consequences across a
whole gamut of data
there's a great website to this effect i
would just encourage listeners to check
out called
wtf happened in 1971.com
and it you know we've had obesity
suicide
uh addiction clearly global debt to gdp
has exploded
um it just points towards the the
devastating force that is
arbitrary inflation um
so yeah i hope that answers it can i
yes go ahead and just jump in for a sec
before we move on
we're talking a lot about value and i
think jordan you mentioned something
earlier that i just wanted to pull the
string on a tiny little bit
is and you talk about this in your work
but you when we
in order for value to emerge right we
need
to define limitations so things are
defined by their limitations and as a
result of that
we're able to separate them right so
things
emerge out of the void their limitations
allow us to separate them
then the problem is how do we order them
right and then so that is how these
value hierarchies
emerge and the the internal measuring
stick we use
to order things is our own limitations
of time and energy
so for a very basic example if i'm going
to look at the lamp
then i'm excluding everything else that
i could look at i'm
devoting my time and energy resources to
look at that lamp at the exclusion of
everything else the opportunity cost is
infinite
to anywhere you place your limited
resources
and so the the journey or the evolution
of money of finding a money has been to
try to find something
that mimics our limitations that mimics
the sacrifices that we make
uh when we de when we bestow value on
something
so why would you why would you say
mimics
well because we want something to
reflect the same limitation you know
when we're bestowing value on something
through our sacrifices
that's basically what value is i'm
sacrificing my time and energy and
perception to focus on one particular
thing
if i want to express that out into the
external world
the ideal way of doing that is to find
something that is similarly
limited as my own so that's interesting
so yeah so
money i mean it's obvious in one sense
that money is a reflection of human
value but
i hadn't exactly thought about it as a
form of mimicry so what we want is an
on an arbitrary external agent that's
move mo mobile across people that
signifies what people value of course so
that's significant
value structure why sacrifice
well that's how we create wealth in the
world we sacrifice our time and energy
to create things
so money that's just another definition
i didn't mean to interrupt money as a
measure of sacrifice
okay gigi let's go to you now and let's
fill in some of the gaps about bitcoin
per se do you want to
fill us in about what it is and and why
you think it's significant what's
revolutionary about it i'll try my best
and i'll try to
link it towards what's just discussed
like we we always try to zero in on
something that
um yeah doesn't just melt away and that
that we can use as money and
historically as we just discussed
gold and silver precious metals were
very good at that because gold is
virtually indestructible and it's also
very scarce and visible and so on and so
forth
the problem is and that's what computer
scientists tried to solve
uh like for i guess 50 years plus
is if you want to do that in the
informational realm have
something that represents value it's
basically impossible because you can
copy information
indefinitely and that's what's what's
described by the double spend problem
like if you can read information you can
also
you can also copy it so you cannot have
a token in the
digital realm that can't be copied if
you can read it you can also write it
down again and that's a basic copying
mechanism
that's how computers work computers are
just basic copying machines so digital
scarcity is kind of an
oxymoron and was never possible before
bitcoin and also in bitcoin like the way
that bitcoin works
it doesn't produce anything that can't
be copied everything in bitcoin is
copied all the time and you can copy
every aspect of it and there is also
nothing that is really encrypted you
know it uses
it uses encryption technology like
cryptographic technology
but it doesn't really encrypt anything
it only uses digital signature
schemes to make sure that the ownership
of things is clear but you can read any
everything in bitcoin is completely
plain text that's why we also say it's
speech you know it's
you can you can basically print out how
bitcoin works and put it in the book and
you can actually read it and you can
feed it into another computer and
just spin it up again and also the
output that bitcoin produces this ledger
which records
who owns what is completely plain text
like you can make sense of it by just
looking at it kind of and so
we we have this problem that
historically we found
physical artifacts to represent this
value
gold coins for example and the gold
coins they speak for themselves like
whoever has the gold coin
is in possession of this value the
stored value someone else put work
into it to extract the gold first and
foremost and after exchanges
you know that whoever earned this gold
coin or also stole it like
it doesn't matter whoever has this
bearer instrument whoever has this gold
coin
is in possession of some value and can
redeem it
um go to society and redeem it you can
like
whatever goods and services you want to
have you can exchange your gold coin for
that
and in the digital realm doing that
without any trusted third party
before bitcoin was impossible because of
this double spend problem because
of the nature of information that you
can't have any
token that can't be copied so what
bitcoin actually does
is it it is this play kind of it is this
intricate dance of
computers all around the world that spin
up a system
that checks and verifies copies of this
ledger
and it makes invalid copies useless
so you can copy it and you can kind of
transform the copies as well
but everyone who participates
voluntarily in this game
agrees to certain rules and the rules
say that we only accept
valid copies according to the rules that
we signed up to
and this is what makes all this possible
and what what comes
what comes out of it is simply it's an
unbreakable
contract of trust yeah it's like
unbreakable is a really big word
and everything in bitcoin works kind of
probabilistically including like
cryptography itself it's it's it's
basically it makes use of an
asymmetry that some problems in our
universe
are very hard to solve unless you know
the exact solution to it
so that's basically all like the root of
all cryptography like if i know the
secret i can decipher the message
instantly very easily but if you don't
know the secret
you will have to guess every possible
secret and this is where this
asymmetry of power comes from so
cryptography is inherently defensive and
this is what uh bitcoin makes use of as
well like if you don't have my private
key
you cannot spend my bitcoin period like
the heat death of the universe will come
first before you
you will be able to do that and this is
the power of bitcoin
so can you get extremely simple and
describe what bitcoin is
yeah that's the 21 million
bitcoin question i'm afraid there is no
simple answer like the the best i can
give you is
it's basically you can think of it as a
as a shared excel sheet like
shared a shared a shared ledger
that simply attests to who owes what to
whom
like it has a list of these are the 21
million
bitcoins that we have and john owns some
and robert owns some and it's a list of
transfers so it's a list of transactions
and if you if you add all this up and
and make sense of all the transactions
it's the
the what is recorded is from
the genesis of bitcoin up to the present
moment
everything that happened in the bitcoin
ecosystem and so that's true
that's what makes it trade exactly
ownership that's what
that's what makes it so trustworthy it's
like a it's a computerized accountant
it's keeping track of who owes who owns
what and who owes
who what and it's distributed everywhere
so no one can corrupt it
and you can't get access to anyone's
store because their
key is encrypted in a way that makes it
impossible to break
it's it's because everyone holds their
own keys in the best case
like i i hold my own keys and you don't
you don't even know like you can't
associate um my bitcoin addresses with
myself
um that's also why i'm an invisible man
so a lot of bitcoiners
uh take care about their privacy and
that's a big
like a big topic in the bitcoin world as
well and so there is simply no attack
vector you cannot
like you cannot invade all the homes of
all the bitcoiners across the world and
steal the private key so that's what you
would have to do to break the whole
system so the security is distributed
in the sense that uh the security is at
the edges and the system itself is
insanely resilient and what enables this
trust
is exactly as you have said it's it's
transparent and it's
radically distributed everyone has a
copy so i can check it for myself
from from from the very first block like
the genesis of bitcoin
up to the present moment i can verify
everything myself
right so it's completely transparent
it's completely distributed there's no
centralized authority
it can't be cracked it can't be stolen
it doesn't inflate it can't be inflated
um it isn't subject to at least so far
to any form of
overt administrative control so let me
ask all of you guys a question maybe
john and richard can chime in in this
because they haven't spoken too much yet
so one of the questions might arise
especially in relationship to robert's
comments is that we switched to a fiat
currency back in 1971 and obviously you
guys are no
fans of fiat currencies but we do have
money and
it does work we we can still it still
stores value we can still spend it and
so i would say please tell me why i'm
wrong or if i'm wrong or if you agree
the american dollar has been the
currency of record essentially since
1971 perhaps since before that despite
the fact that
we've switched to a fiat exchange system
and my sense is the reason that people
use the american dollar is because
the judgment of the world is that by and
large
the social structure of the united
states social and economic structure
of the united states is such that it's
more reliable than any alternative and
so people trust
them individual americans in some sense
they trust the trusted interrelationship
they have with each other they
trust the emergent social institutions
and
and and as a consequence of that they're
willing to put the same kind of faith
into the dollar that you guys put into
bitcoin
and so that's working and so so what's
the problem exactly and is there
something wrong with my reasoning
maybe richard you could comment on that
and if not someone else jump in
well i think we have we can make a
fundamental distinction between
a money that is chosen by the free
market
and a money that is forced upon
someone um by the use of the threat of
force which is essentially what the us
dollar is and and any other fiat
currency
your point is is well taken which is
that the us dollar works
as money but i guess the question is in
relation to
to what uh or compared to what and and i
think that
um because we we sort of can't imagine
this um
this universe that doesn't exist where
you know the free market was simply
allowed to do to do what it
what it would do um so
there's there's two problems with
with the um the us dollar one is that
um yeah it's it's basically it's imposed
by this legal tender law so
so in the united states and and yes the
united states has
um economic and political dominance and
that extends around the world but
citizens in the united states aren't
free to
transact in money that they choose if i
wanted to
make a transaction in gold i'm legally
not
allowed to do that i'm not allowed to
denominate a contract in gold
and i'm also in a technical sense
prevented from
saving my money in gold and that's
really because of
capital gains taxes if
if i want to want to use gold for
example to
to protect my savings from debasement
because
slowly but surely the value of the us
dollar does
decline over time if i then want to go
and
use that saved money um to actually make
a transaction because i'm legally
obliged to
i have to pay a capital gains tax and
and sort of
give back to the to the state um the
value
i've tried to save so i think
yeah there's a utilitarian domain so you
wouldn't regard that
you wouldn't regard necessarily any
increase in value that pertain to
investment in gold as an actual capital
gain you'd
be more inclined i may be putting words
in your mouth i hope not but
you'd be more inclined to think of that
as a hedge against inflation and so not
an increase in wealth but an actual
maintenance of wealth because gold
hypothetically is more reliable than the
dollar you could make that case
so exactly correct and this is the thing
is that
you know gold holding gold is is yes
technically it's not an investment
because there's no
there's no return but the other
interesting thing is that things that
that we put our money money into these
days that are investments such as
real estate or shares and things like
that
most people are only doing that in an
effort yeah not to earn a real return
but only to sort of offset
the loss of value that comes from the
slowly depreciating
currency so you know that's part of the
problem of
of having a currency where the supply
constantly inflates
is that people are aren't able to simply
save money in a simple sense they're not
able to hold
money they have to take that money and
invest it and take on the inherent risk
in investing
simply to maintain their purchasing
power over time
and then that that's basically that
purchasing power is taken away from them
again
when they try and go rotate out of that
investment back into money okay so let
me ask you a question about that
so maybe i could make a case that you
know because we're all interdependent
whenever i generate wealth i generate it
as a consequence of my interdependence
with other people
i wouldn't be able to do it on my own
i'm dependent on the infrastructure i'm
dependent on the government
or at least i i have the advantages that
those things provide me
and so could i not make a case that if
i've managed to accrue a substantial
uh sum of of excess capital savings
that it's reasonable for the rest of
society to expect me to allow some of
that to inflate away
as a tax on my hoarding as a consequence
of the fact that
part of my wealth is generated as part
of a shared endeavor
because you know you could posit a
wealth tax right that might
address inequality so that there's a two
percent wealth tax or something like
that on fortunes over 500 million
dollars and so they decay with time to
restore that hoarded wealth back to the
general community
do you what do you think of an argument
like that
well there's a the problem
well a lot of this comes back to um you
know we have to go right back to first
principles
about what we think about the nature of
the government or the state like do we
think that that institution
helps or hinders do we think that that
institution
can actually redistribute resources
in a way that's fair and equitable um
and can it kind of do that efficiently
that's
almost an entirely different question
you know i tend to be very skeptical
of what uh what the state can do in that
respect
and i think that freely acting
individuals would possibly be able to do
a better job
um so you have a baby you basically have
a free market
response to that objection that the free
market is going to do better as a
calculating device
absolutely and the only other thing i'll
quickly say before i think about handing
over is that
the problem with using inflation as a
redistributive method
is that it actually unfairly um
works against the poor people in society
because those that have
wealth um you know you're talking about
a wealth
worth tax or or that sort of happens
through inflation but
the way that it generally plays out is
those people who are wealthy they don't
store their money as dollars they store
it in
assets and those assets appreciate
in value as a result of the inflation
whereas those people who are
living on fixed wages salaries you know
living week to week with a bank balance
there and because they're spending a
larger proportion of their money
on on goods and services they're the
ones who are actually most
unfairly um targeted by inflation so
it actually has the effect of increasing
inequality
and do why do you guys have any faith in
in the idea that there is actually
measurable inflation because
i i is it reasonable
i don't understand inflation there's a
basket of goods and services that are
calculated the
price of them is calculated every year
but what's in that basket of goods and
services seems to me to be a relatively
arbitrary choice i mean
what makes you think that there has in
fact been
objectively reliable inflation say over
the last 30 years given
for example that many many manufactured
goods and so forth have got dramatically
cheaper now i know housing in many
places has skyrocketed you know
to to a tremendous degree but do you do
you really feel that the
the currency has become corrupted and
that you can
you can and what do you rely on to make
that case what data do you rely on
i could jump in here i think um i would
say unquestionably
debasement of the currency it is
an arbitrary harvesting of the economic
surplus
a productive free market economy is
creating
so as an economy gets more efficient
it generates more wealth that's passed
back into mark two market actors in the
form of declining prices
so we're getting smarter at making
chairs smarter providing services
electronics all these things
but by printing money you're basically
stealing claims on that productive on
that economic surplus and doling it out
arbitrarily
so we could say another way to think
about this is that the free market
itself
as you've described jordan it's a
distributed computing system
so we all have our you know 120 bits per
second
conscious attention span you multiply
that out by
8 billion market participants that is
the
cognitive power of the free market right
i want to emphasize that because because
it's
such an important point and it could
easily be skipped over because
you know there are people who admire the
ideas of central planning and you think
well maybe there's 40 people doing your
central planning and so maybe they're
the smartest people in the world
and they're doing your central planning
but they have to
calculate on the fly a virtually
infinite amount of information
if they don't have free market prices at
their disposal
they have to calculate what metal is
worth what nails are worth what
labor is worth what rubber is worth what
cleanup is worth what nursing is worth
etc etc and they have to do all those
comparisons
and they have to do those computations
and there's actually no way even
technically of doing that and the
alternative is to distribute that
calculation across a virtually infinite
number of actors or actors in the
billions at least
and let every single person act as a
computational device and some all that
and that's what the free market does
it's not it's not even in principle
replaceable by a
logical cognitive mechanism i can't see
how it is that's exactly right
it's not even possible that a
centralized bureaucracy
a centralized computing model can
compete with a distributed computing
model of the free market
we could actually in fact say that the
free market is a pure economic democracy
people are voting by buying and selling
and whatever price is generated on any
given asset that's effectively the truth
of what it trades at
any intervention on that any
intervention any regulation
any pricing czar as they had in the ussr
you move towards you move along that
spectrum towards an economic tyranny
where we have now the arbitrary wishes
of a few overriding
what the free market democracy is
selecting
and to tie this back to the problems
with dollar the dollar is
you know the dollar was gold by the way
fiat currency never emerges on the free
market that distributed computing model
never selects a fiat currency by itself
it's only when uh natural law is
violated when they step across the line
of life liberty and property and say i'm
going to impose this technology on you
or
else that's the only time fiat currency
has ever emerged
and in fact the dollar itself was just
kind of a bait and switch it was
something redeemable for free market
money gold
that was then replaced with this this
compelled money and again if money is
speech
we could say then that fiat currency is
effectively compelled speech
it's the same thing they're forcing a
language a language of value they're
forcing its use on you
and though if you boil it down to brass
tax the us dollar today and all fiat
currencies
they are mechanically their pyramid
schemes
so a pyramid scheme is a
a system of network marketing basically
that's using
uh that's useful for enriching those in
higher tiers at the expense of those and
lower tiers
and you're constantly recruiting more uh
lower tiers to enrich the top
okay so let me let me draw an objection
to that just briefly so let's
i'm going to accept the pyramid scheme
hypothesis
but i'm going to say that it's a pyramid
scheme that sacrifices the future to the
present
but that doesn't matter because the
future is going to be so much more
productive than the present that we can
afford that leverage
it would be so to make this is the
kernel of economics right is that i can
delay
consumption or gratification today
invest for the future and then enjoy
more in the future
fiat currency and central planning more
generally
uh reverses that it actually it induces
you to consume and take on debt today
and disregard the future this is the
raising of the time preference that we
spoke to earlier
so that and it's arbitrary nature
again it it's as mises would describe
all centrally planned action is
it runs countervailing to what the free
market would choose on its own so you're
no matter what you do the government
cannot make a good decision if they're
if they're
coercing people to do it because they're
withdrawing productive factors from the
economy
to fund that decision if they want to go
to war for instance
the market may have not selected to go
to war but a government has decided that
no we're going to
pull these productive factors from the
economy and push us into warfare
so it's it's contradictory to the the
essence of democracy itself right so you
guys really see that
bitcoin as it just you really do see it
as a distributed form of government
as well in disruptive to centralized
government yes
yeah and and i think one of the elements
of inflation and again this is the
string back to what we were
talking about earlier and i do think it
is a fundamental point to make but
it it if money is how we express
our sacrifices and therefore our values
into the matrix of value
hierarchies that exist in the market
then inflation is doing so
without the commensurate sacrifices that
everyone else
needs to make into it to allow them to
communicate that to the market
and so this is where the idea of
pathological hierarchies is applicable
is because a naturally emerging market
where the fidelity between
one's actions one's choices one's
valuations and the signal that they send
out into the market is pristine and i
would make the case that's what
bitcoin um represents whenever that is
diluted in whatever
capacity you know to a small degree or
to a larger degree
that's what creates incongruencies
between the matrix of value hierarchies
that are out in the market
if they are pristine if we are all able
to communicate
with perfection our value hierarchies to
the market
we will see in my opinion emergent order
i don't see how it could be any other
way where that gets thrown off
is when that signal that we're sending
carries all alternative information
not information that we you know through
our divine
process of you know mediating chaos in
order to
bestow value on things and then express
that through our actions
not that process but through some other
process of someone who controls the
mechanism by which we communicate that
and so inflation is just is changing the
relationship between
the matrix of value hierarchies without
the commensurate sacrifices and that is
what creates pathological hierarchies
and that's what creates
you mentioned you know the inequality of
devices why do we why do we allow this
with now we don't we're not going to
degenerate into conspiratorial thinking
and i'm always wary of any conversation
that involves
they you know an external actor like we
we've allowed this as a
as a global community and if if
what we've done is flawed in the manner
that your analysis indicates
why have we allowed it to happen i could
say who benefits
and we could go there to begin with but
again as i said i'm very leery of
conspiratorial thinking i tend to think
of large-scale social problems as
everybody's problem you know but
so so what do you think about that why
why have we allowed this to happen and
let's say who benefits and why
well and who suffers i'm with you and i
of the time i attribute um you know the
things that we see in the world that we
might term evil or bad to incompetence
and not
uh right evil yeah not malevolent um i
think
you know there's there's many factors
here but one
is it happens kind of it happens in slow
motion
and so people end up not being able to
see it for example like you would say
today hey
i got my iphone i got netflix we're
talking on zoom
things are good and right in the world
and i you know i know oftentimes
you discuss not to you know discredit
not to go out and try to change the
world not to be too
critical of of of the state of the world
because the order that we experience is
almost miraculous
but i would say that there's an element
of that that may cause you not to see
the how things have become disordered i
mean it's it's difficult to see that and
so when we talk about
the uh disruptive effect of inflation
that i just alluded to
a lot of people have a difficult time
seeing that we can
objectively isolate problems that are
going on in the world
inequality and social problems and you
know all the craziness that we see in
the world
and we could tribute that to fill in the
blank cause whereas
i think what we attribute most of that
to is the disordering that
results from this fractured congruence
of value hierarchies that are being
communicated in a market that's where i
think most of that comes from
but it it takes time to play so it's a
form of
faulty information right and we are we
are leveraging right now or we are
um still benefiting from this
the the order the the the structure that
was imposed as a result of let's say
being on a gold standard and the
political and social dynamic that that
fosters
in many cases we've been living off the
stability that that fosters for the for
the last several decades
i think you could make a case that
despite technological advancement that
may
might cause us to think hey things you
know aren't so bad or may cause to
distract us
i think you can make the case that the
equity that we've been living off of
that stability is coming to an end
and i think we're seeing that in many
different cases but you know i think
that's why
it happens in slow motion and people are
not educated enough or necessarily
paying attention enough to notice the
relationship between
all the different things that are going
on okay so let me ask you guys a
question about what happened in 2008 and
so
and i may be completely wrong about this
but my understanding was that the
the 2008 crisis was fundamentally
produced by a technological revolution
and the technological revolution was
something like the realization that you
could take
investments of a certain risk
level mortgages let's say substandard
mortgages
and by bundling them together in huge
tranches and huge
groups you could quantify the risk
and as a consequence of quantifying the
risk you could discount you could make
the
the group of of of investments more
valuable than they would be as the sum
of the individual investments
which i thought was a brilliant
innovation and so now
these companies banks traded these huge
tranches of
subprime mortgages because they could
quantify the risk
and that means that that could be
accounted for financially and so the
risk was ameliorated and
the the flaw was well no one realized
that doing so
on mass would increase the probability
that housing prices would become
correlated
across time across huge geographical
regions for example across the entire
united states
and so the housing market could collapse
all at once but
so so i you could make the case that
that was actually a flaw
in the free market computing prowess
because a technological innovation came
along warped the entire system and then
what had to happen was the political
system had to rescue it
and so i watched that and i thought well
did i was the political system
embedded in the economic system which is
i think the argument you guys are
fundamentally making or
is the economic system embedded in the
political system and
is what's wrong with my analysis of what
happened in 2008 what
wasn't it the case that the the market
was rescued by the
by the political actors is that
incorrect
the arson is putting out the fire sorry
go ahead yeah
no i could start and you guys feel free
to jump in so i would first
encourage you um to look into what's
called the euro dollar system
which is essentially these this
we control the pyramid scheme in the us
the domestic dollar supply but there's
this offshore derivative system where
everyone's trying to peg the dollars
that the central bank doesn't control
that's actually
um been considered to be at the root of
the 2008 crisis and then
this was kind of a cover story but if we
just get back to
error so we could say risk is error
right so there was this embedded
risk that we thought we had calculated
and contained
but what was actually happening is
because we have centrally planned money
it's pushing hidden risk into the
economy
right because the free market
distributed intelligence intelligence
being defined as error correction
it's mitigated by the central planning
of money so these hidden risks
accumulate
and that's why we've had increased
volatility since 1971
we have these huge economic booms we
print a bunch of money inflation runs
hot but so do assets everyone thinks
they're doing really well
and then we have these catastrophic
retracements back to economic reality
and actually that's because incremental
incremental reaction to risk is not
is not being implemented that's where
you're diverging perceptions from
reality
effectively so even the the correction
in march 2020 that was the sharpest
liquidity collapse in the history of
markets it was faster than 1929.
so we would expect as more fiat currency
which is artificial liquidity is pumped
into the system
it's further distorting this economic
perceptual faculty
and creates even more volatile boom and
busts this is the austrian business
cycle theory in a nutshell um
and the only way the only way to resolve
this is to let the free market clear
errors that's what it does
that's what consciousness does too by
the way so you think of the free market
as our
are interconnected consciousnesses
mediated by the price signal
when you disturb the price signal our
consciousnesses become divided
and we have increased errors and
blow-ups well that's why i
suggest to people that they don't engage
in deception because they distort the
value signals and they warp their own
consciousness it's a very dangerous
thing to do
that's right because you only have to
use deception that's exactly what
money does that's exactly what fiat
money does
fiat currency is a living lie that's
what that's that's it in a nutshell
and maybe to to bring this home the
question you asked could also be
a rephrase to to pick a more like
an example that people might be familiar
with you could also ask like
was the drug addict or was uh the person
suffering from alcoholism saved by
alcohol because he suffered withdrawal
and that's
like a very similar question and then
you could argue yes we gave
we gave him the substance and he
survived so it was a good thing
and he made it through but what would
actually be necessary is kind of you
know like
that's not the cure you you you would
need to quit cold turkey and that's what
bitcoiners are arguing or just in
general people advocating for sound
money are arguing
that we need to get off the fiat
standard that can be arbitrarily
manipulated and manipulates the price
signals manipulates the whole economy
okay so that's a fundamental tenet of
austria austrian economics is
essentially that central planning
in relationship to the monetary supply
that isn't informed by
incremental free market decisions
produces
error that accumulates and produces
cyclical
booms and busts that's very interesting
because there is a psychological analog
to that that psychological analog to
that is failure to
react to error when they're committed
incrementally
to store the errors up which compound
across time and to collapse and the
oldest myths
which i talk about maps of meaning talk
about for example the re-emergence of
tiamat in the mesopotamian
myth which is the consequence of
corruption
accumulates and produces catastrophe
it's the flood myth idea essentially
so the business cycle theory in austrian
economics is a recast of the flood myth
and the tower of babel is that right
because those are the two
parallels the two mythological parallels
the tower of babel is administrative
overload essentially and and the
corruption of systems and the flood is
you know the catastrophe the the
downside of the
of the or the natural catastrophe i
would say
so i think you hit on one of the main
points of of this discussion generally
is that
truth is represented across scales maybe
that's part of the definition of truth
is that you can see it
across scales it's represented in
different forms it's certainly that part
of the definition of deep truth
right and so it's definitely when we
look at maps of meaning you know i think
this is part of the
reason why we're so interesting and talk
interested in talking about it
is because we take those truths that are
seemingly entirely unrelated to markets
and money
you know it's all about it's all about
mediating the forces of nature the
structure of reality in conjunction with
the social relationships that constitute
life and trying to figure out
what behavior is most the most optimal
balance between the two
and uh i think we could carry that over
to
money and markets and no it's funny
because you know maps of meaning could
have been called maps of value and
obviously money is a map of value but i
hadn't drawn the
analogy between a map of value and money
although in retrospect that seems like
an obvious thing to do which is why i
got interested in your
idea about on incorruptable money yeah
and so you think of incorruptable money
as a computational as computationally
advantageous essentially that's
that's the basis of the idea yeah and
and i think again
to pursue this i think bitcoin is
the regenerative hero in different form
it
takes the forces of nature it it it
digs into chaos into pure entropy into
pure energy and let's say mathematics
and spits out
the greatest form of order that we as
human beings use in the social realm
which is money and it does so in the
archetypal way in the
maximal possible way of doing so and it
does so in an incorruptible manner
and so if you take a lot you know if you
take those things
you could easily you know that could
easily have been talking about the
regenerative hero as described in
maps of meaning and i think it's
represented in bitcoin it's instantiated
in bitcoin
and that's why it's having such a
revelatory effect provides a really
weird bridge between the objective world
in the world of value too doesn't it
because all the computation
occurs in objective like that's
objectively real
and that objectively real incorruptible
computation produces an unerring signal
of value or that's the theory at least
okay so let's talk practically for a bit
so
then we'll return to the central
discussion i mean uh
elon musk is recently objected to
bitcoin on the basis of and maybe this
is is this a flaw
bitcoin becomes more and more expensive
to produce as we proceed through time
and the consequence of that is that we
do in fact use up more energy or at
least that's
in one form which is computational
energy maybe we
gain that back and you know efficiencies
within the market itself
you could argue that but what do you
think about musk's recent decision with
regard to bitcoin
i would love to jump in on that because
i have written about that extensively
and
i think um what you said is exactly
right that
bitcoin is a map of value so to speak
and what's so interesting about bitcoin
is that bitcoin is both the map
and the territory and as i've said
before in the
informational realm we cannot we cannot
link
usually like we cannot link the map to
the territory you cannot do it like if
if you have something in the real world
writing something down about it you will
always
have to trust the person that wrote it
down and what's so ingenious
in in the world of bitcoin is bitcoin
uses the only thing you can do with
information which is to transform it
to anchor it to the real world so this
is what proof of work does that's what
the ex the energy expenditure is for
for and the energy is used for various
things
so it's it's used to secure the system
it's used to
distribute new coins it's used to make
sure that the history becomes
incorruptible so it also secures the
past so it does
a couple of things it also makes sure
like
it even decentralizes time itself which
sounds kind of weird but it's very
hard to keep a decentralized system
synchronous because of relativity and
other effects so
you would have if you wouldn't have
something like physical proof of work
you would need to trust a central
authority in terms of time
because the order of things like the
order of transactions needs an absolute
order of time
and all these all these things combined
are solved by
the the proof of work system that uh
satoshi nakamoto introduced
and so the end like the energy
expenditure
the basic question becomes once you
realize that the basic question becomes
is it worth it
and society in general yeah
society in general asks this question
about all kinds of things like our cars
worth it our smartphones worth it is the
internet worth it all these things they
they take up a lot of energy and bitcoin
us argue that bitcoin is definitely
worth it for this for the sound money
aspect alone musk is
determining by fiat that it isn't well
instead of letting the market decide
it's it's very hard to um decipher
uh what what musk meant with his recent
comments because
uh tesla is still holding uh like
a lot of bitcoin on their balance sheet
i think it's about 2 billion
us dollars worth in bitcoin and they
don't intend to sell any and so
um you know like it's it's a political
game to
to um like
so let me ask you this if you guys are
right just tell me if i'm leaping
somewhere i shouldn't be here but
what should happen is that whatever
energy is expended
in the production of bitcoin and the
maintenance of the system
should be more than recoup by the
increased efficiency of every system
that use bitcoin as a
transactional device and so the net
energy there'll be a net energy gain not
a net energy loss if you calculated it
across the entire system
and so it's a mistake just to look at
the cost of generating bitcoin in the
absence of considering the efficiencies
that bitcoin would produce
and the same is true for for gold as
well you know like it takes a lot of
energy to extract gold from the ground
and historically
society in general uh answered this
question in the affirmative yes
it's way worth it like it's it's worth
to dig this up and
um right but there were limits right
because once the or
becomes insufficiently rich at some
point you stop
refining it so so there's a there's a
limit but
according to your logic at least the the
limit on the energy expenditure that
bitcoin produces should be produced by
the market response to bitcoin not by
some fiat judgment about whether or not
it's
like ecologically sustainable because
that's just a guess
and the best indicator that we have for
ecological stability is going to be
cumulative free market decisions even
though those aren't necessarily very
good they're better than anything else
we could possibly generate rationally
and just to clarify one point and then
i'll let
robert dig into this bitcoin like
doesn't take energy because the
production of bitcoin takes energy the
production of bitcoin it's an
emission schedule so it's constant we
know when the last bitcoin will be mined
it's
it's going to be around in 2140 and it
doesn't matter how much energy you
expend it won't be it won't go quicker
it won't go slower so
if you if you dig harder for it it will
be harder to find
and if you stop digging for it it will
get easier to find so that's the
the genius invention of the difficulty
adjustment so there is no one-to-one
link
of bitcoin production and energy
expanded the and the
the energy is used for different things
for its security for example
and uh robert i think you you want to
say a few things yeah yeah i'll try to
dovetail and tie some things together so
the general tenet here is there is no
value in money without sacrifice
we there has to be an energy expenditure
to secure
the supply of money or the network of
money that's what ensures against its
corruption
basically and if if we zoom out it
wouldn't cost anything
that's right and someone would just
arbitrarily suck value out of it by
printing it right that's what the
central bank is designed to do
so if we zoom out a little further we
could say the entire purpose of the
world economy
is to increase collective energy
efficiency that's wow
that's why we are trading and
specializing that's what profits are
actually right that's an indication that
we have free energy
provided we satisfy to want more
efficiently
and that that rewarded profits of the
entrepreneur that then invites more
competition more production etc etc
so back to john's point the entrepreneur
this is the
the individual element that courageously
faces the chaos of nature
right with his skin in the game his his
own capital plans etc
um trying to convert it into good and
useful order the entrepreneur is the
living hero myth
and that's what the free market honors
it it honors the sacrifices that
entrepreneurs go out into the world and
make for us
whereas something like uh bureaucracy is
antithetical to that so
to get back to your your point about why
central banking how did we allow it to
happen
i boil it down to this is that even the
entrepreneur he's pursuing
something for nothing he's trying to
find a way to satisfy wants more cheaply
more efficiently
to enrich himself and to enrich others
that axis you talk about between chaos
and order good and evil
right we're all pursuing something for
nothing but there's a point where you
can
cross that axis into the domain of evil
where it's intentionally
harmful to others to to benefit
ourselves
i think that's what central banking has
has done right it's
the entrepreneur wants something for
nothing by figuring out how to provide a
good or service but so does the central
bank
but it's it's crossed that divide to
where it's actually
economically harming others to give its
shareholders its private shareholders a
perpetual
economic free lunch it has no sacrifice
in the money creation process
it pays a dividend to undisclosed
shareholders it it's a parasite
on the productive economy effectively
and i would say that
no one is better than their incentives
right it's not like how did we let this
happen it's like there was just an
attack vector on gold there's
technological shortcomings of gold
that allowed it to be corrupted that's
how we got the central bank
built on top of gold so i think by
introducing
bitcoin a money that's really hard to
steal
in terms of inflation or confiscation it
it pushes us to be more hardworking as a
society
because that is the only profitable
strategy we become entrepreneurial
whereas if money is easy to steal like
it is under the central bank model via
inflation
we slide towards kleptocracy right and
that's what you see
even elon he's very close to the fiat i
like the wii technology a lot better you
know because
because it does you make a case there
you make a case for a kind of
technological inadequacy is that
as a species we haven't been able to
generate a sufficiently incorruptable
language of value and that has produced
all sorts of negative consequences some
of which you're outlining it's a problem
that we all have
okay so practically speaking guys
bitcoin
it's not easy to spend it's not you
can't go into a store and spend it like
it doesn't have that portability that
you
described robert as a cardinal element
of a necessary currency and
it isn't obvious to me that it's been
rapidly moving in that direction but
that may be a mere consequence of my
ignorance um
or or my time scale maybe it'll do
happen in 10 years and that's virtually
instant from a historical perspective i
mean how do you think
do you think bitcoin can leap the
gap between its what would you say
somewhat
story yeah yeah yes that's right exactly
can i just hop in real quick on the last
point before we answer this and
then we'll get to it but jordan you
mentioned um you know is this energy
expenditure
and the environmental issues around
bitcoin is it worthwhile
right and as you said the market is the
best thing to determine
whether something is worthwhile or not i
tend to think of our impact on the
planet not as a planet in isolation
but but as in human flourishing i mean
isn't that what we should be looking at
when we talk about the environment not
just is the natural world harmed in some
way but
is our way otherwise we're just talking
about maximizing someone's ideological
perception
exactly this is what the environment
should be right so
i think our question should be what is
basically the ratio
between the consumption of resources and
the human flourishing that it nets
and i think that money because it's the
thing that allows you to determine the
relative worthwhile of ever
worthwhileness of everything else it
means that there is nothing
more important than that object so
whatever the free market selects
as the as the money the resources used
to instantiate that to perpetuate it are
definitionally worthwhile because it
permits
the the relative valuation of everything
else downstream of it
i just wanted to get that piece out yeah
yeah fair point a fair point
if i might jump in in terms of like
you can't go to the corner shop and
spend your bitcoin i
i would say you know that's a fair
criticism but that was true 20 years ago
for e-commerce and uh other technologies
so it it happens gradually then suddenly
like
that was the same criticism was like
what what am i gonna do with a
smartphone
what am i gonna do with the internet
election
it doesn't work yet you know yeah and
electricity a lot of bitcoins
uh or some bitcoins like to use this
metaphor because bitcoin is also a
network and electricity is also network
so
you have network effects and they they
um take a while
to to grow but bitcoin is very usable
already and there are a lot of people
already living on a bitcoin standard so
they're earning bitcoin they're spending
bitcoin they're using bitcoin
day-to-day currently because we are
still in this early adoption phase
and bitcoin is an exponential technology
built up on other exponential
technologies so
it it lives on the internet and it uses
like smartphones and other devices that
are exponential in nature
to to propagate itself then it's it will
just
take a while until it is ubiquitous but
i think also it is unstoppable just like
the internet was you know the internet
dematerialized all kinds of things and
it just took a little bit to play out
and netflix wasn't possible from day one
and video zoom calls that we are having
right now weren't possible from day one
and very similarly bitcoin is evolving
and uh
building itself up in layers and
currently its main use
is as a censorship resistant money
if you are not allowed to have a bank
account for whatever reason
bitcoin serves you very well and if you
if you want to
have a long-term store of value bitcoin
is
an excellent choice of storage value as
well and just
look at at the data like historically
year over year
bitcoin compared to the us dollar gained
200 so if you put some money in bitcoin
if you have done that in the past
you you are better off than having money
on the bank account or under your
mattress
because of the inflationary nature of
fiat currencies that we discussed
and i think it will just it will just
continue
to evolve just like the internet did and
people will find it
useful for various different reasons and
now you regard it as unstoppable and so
on what basis do you make that claim why
do you believe that
bitcoin is pure information it is pure
information and also
the system that is running it like the
the asset itself is pure information i
can store
12 words in my head and i have bitcoin
in my head literally
so it is very useful in that regard
that's what makes it
that what makes it virtually um
resistant to
to um yeah nobody can take it away from
you like if you secure it properly
bitcoin has
certain properties that allows you to
um make sure that you and only you can
spend the bitcoin
and on the system side of things the
bitcoin network itself
it's just computer code and so it's just
information and
we as a society are very good at making
sure that
um important information information
that various people regard as important
survives so we we often like to
compare bitcoin to other informational
texts just like the bible for example
that outlast empires
because it is it is very hard to destroy
pure information if it is distributed
well enough and the whole reason
for the bitcoin system to work in a that
complicated manner that it does
is because it maximizes decentralization
it maximizes
censorship resistance the whole idea of
the bitcoin system is to build something
that they can't stop and it doesn't
matter who they are so
it's it's to build a system that we as
humanity
can't stop exactly right right to build
a system that we can't well so that's
well you know that's kind of an
interesting conundrum there too you
you're going to ask yourself
there's no shortage of of um dire
science fiction predictions about the
buildings of systems that we can't even
stop
downsides to bitcoin well how about the
facilitation of criminal activity
underground criminal activity for
example
um and like if you guys put your heads
together and you had to critique bitcoin
as a social danger what would you say
oh there's the there's definitely the
criminal element which seems
immediately relevant i would say it's
it's the same as with every powerful
tool like a chef's knife is a very
dangerous weapon but you can also
prepare beautiful meals with it and we
have to
kind of make sure to wield these
powerful tools
directly but it's also kind of um
you know like the genie is out of the
bottle we
kind of have to just like with the
internet you know like the the internet
and
every other technology before it can
it's just a tool it can be used for good
and bad
and there's plenty of crime facilitated
online as well
and you know like i don't even want to
go into bank robberies and
cars that were early adopted by bank
robbers so that they can run away faster
so i think that would be my answer to
that question
and george just very quickly on that one
you know in your
uh writing and such you detail how
the religious traditions particularly
christianity in our case
have informed the legal system and one
of the
very special ways that it's done so is
that it
sanctifies the sovereignty of the
individual even if that
individual is is has obviously committed
a crime they are given
the right of due process they are
presumed innocent until proven guilty
and this is a technology that
fundamentally sanctifies the sovereignty
of every individual
and what they choose to do with that
sovereignty is
their choice yes you're also making a
case all of you that
the very act of bitcoin sanctifying the
sovereignty of the individual is
actually tilting individuals towards
doing something good rather than
something bad
that there is that it's not just neutral
as gigi was was
was laying it out that there's an
intrinsic ethic to bitcoin that is more
likely to tilt it in a positive
direction
which would be a more what would you say
a more powerful rejoinder to the bitcoin
equals criminality
uh criticism
so the question is is that see that's
what i'm trying to wrestle with here is
okay so let's accept your proposition
that bitcoin is an incorruptible
currency
and that seems fair enough i mean i i
can't come up with an obvious rejoinder
to that
and then so that means that we have an
incorruptible language of value that
enables us to make better decisions
well we do use money to make decisions
i mean sometimes look sometimes when i'm
trying to decide
whether i'll do one thing or another
i'll do the thing that makes more money
because i can't decide any other way
right
it's an obvious way of picking one thing
over another when they're relatively
commensurate
other people seem to value it more
because they'll pay more for it
so it's actually helpful as a cognitive
it's a helpful cognitive tool
pricing obviously because it simplifies
decision making to a tremendous degree
so it's integrally involved with
decision making you could make the case
that in
an economy or in a market that's
properly constituted and structured
structured i.e people's expression of
their values is not corrupted
that you following that signal of
something being more financially
rewarding
is moving toward the good because the
good news is
so that's really what's at the bottom of
this as far as i was concerned that's
what got me so intrigued by what you
were thinking because that's a re that's
an
unbelievably radical claim and it does
right because not your baby is corrupted
right you're basically saying that that
you can you could rely on an
incorruptible currency as an unerring
signal of value
so you're doing all your computation
externally you know in this new book i
wrote beyond order i
made the case that a lot of our sanity
is distributed
like we tend to think of ourselves as
organized within that's part of the
psychoanalytic tradition the
psychological tradition for that matter
we sort of keep ourselves sane if our
psyches are well structured but
a lot of the way we stay sane is by
interacting with other people and
the signals they send us and that we
respond to keep us sane
and you can see we're all going off in
all sorts of weird conspiratorial
directions as a consequence of being
locked down under covid for so long
because everybody's brains are we
haven't been
subjected to enough social correction
for a while because we're isolated and
we all go kind of
off the rails as a consequence so if the
if the value
language is incorruptable then you can
externalize your
your cognition and you can rely on the
market almost completely to make
decisions for you
so you'd buy the cheapest car for
example all things
all other things being equal because the
the calculation would have already been
done for you
i mean there's going to be a bit of
individual idiosyncrasy but
fundamentally the greatest reward would
be climbing the value hierarchy of the
market in aggregate
and then the question becomes what is at
the top
of the value hierarchy of the market of
the collectivity of all people and so
then
in my opinion yes that allows you to
outsource some of your cognitive load
and
and determine where you should deploy
your resources
more easily but i think that also allows
us to contend with what is
and if we can do that then i think we
can solve our problems more easily and
of course the market is
is a massive component of identifying
those things and i think it empowers us
to say
which is a huge part of your message is
when we see things out in the world
that we don't like or agree with our
action is what
changes those things our contribution to
that market
to nudge or shift the matrix of value
hierarchies in whatever way is how we
affect the
is the best way we can affect change
well we do affect change because we buy
things and then there's more of them i
mean
we do make we do have that impact every
time we make a purchasing decision
so that and part of this i would just
add that so sovereignty itself it's the
generative source of sovereignty
it is the logos right so as you've
described in your
your work we we first had thought i
guess you could say then we had action
then we developed speech to describe our
actions and that became embedded in
something like the bible we describe our
moral development across time
and then money we'd say money is the
tech layer on top of that
it is the natural extension of speech
and action that allows us to
as a mode of self-sovereign expression
so when we
uh and that's rooted in the logos the
logos defined as the word or ratio
in greek prices are exchange ratios
denominated in money for again
outsourcing this cognitive load to the
market
it's the same value yeah prices in words
like the
uh you could say prices are speech right
our money is speech expressed through
prices
and when we violate that when we have an
institution
which also we create institutions to do
the same thing we want an institution so
we don't have to think about the
important civilizational operation we
can just rely on the institutional
practice
so we don't need to think about it when
we corrupt that institution tries to
corrupt words or prices
as communism did in the 20th century or
central banking does to prices today
it destroys the generative principle of
order in the world which is individual
sovereignty so that's what bitcoin is
it's just a tool
that maximizes the freedom and the
sovereignty of the individual
empowering them to be entrepreneurial
and then usher in
a more wealthy and abundant world as a
result
and maybe if i go ahead if i tag on to
that i think
you in your work you came to the
conclusion that free speech is paramount
but it's also dangerous but it is good
and we would we would be saying that
bitcoin is free speech money and
along the same lines it is very powerful
and it can be dangerous but it is also
good
so that the net benefit outweighs
everything else all right that is a
great place to end
guys that's a nice natural play stand
gigi john richard
robert thank you very much that i can't
believe that our time is over that flew
by
madly and that's exactly what i was
hoping it would do so it was a pleasure
talking to you guys
um we'll do this again hey and uh i
really appreciate you taking the time to
speak with me and i hope everybody who's
listening
or watching found this engaging and
useful and i'll keep reading what you're
doing and watching what you're doing and
um we'll see how all this transpires
[Music]
you